yes I think China will actually help
pull us out of the economic crisis
they're in but for reasons that may be
different from what others perceive but
fundamentally we need innovation to get
us out of this crisis we can't use the
paradigm of the older the rules of your
in order to be able to solve the
problems of your innovation is key and I
think that the role that china place
because talent knows no borders is going
to be absolutely critical the police
that innovation has to take place is
going to really involve the sector I'm
in which is you know communications and
again I think the cause of not just the
talent pool but our ability to
understand and work with scale China is
going to be absolutely critical so the
answer may not be quite what you guys
were expecting I think China has a key
role to play with it the role is
associated with how talent innovates and
how communications place it over the net